[Musique]
réfléchir à la naissance du mouvement le
mêler à la danse contemporaine avec kat
à alain guyard mail art martial et break
une rencontre évident pour la
chorégraphe disciples assidus c'était
tout à fait logique pour moi de faire un
spectacle qui mélange le break et les
arts martiaux parce que je vois le break
la danse hip hop comme un art martial
contemporain qui sert un petit peu à
lutter contre l'enfermement du corps
dans l'environnement urbain contre les
formes violentes de la ville et qui nous
permet de lutter aussi pour développer
une personnalité forte dans un
environnement on est tous un peu anonyme
avec kat à alien veut aller au-delà du
mouvement et de la performance partager
quelque chose de spirituel
la philosophie de l'art martial c'est un
peu cinématographique pas ce que je fait
aussi référence au film d'arts martiaux
donc on a un peu l'impression de
travelling de changements de scènes
parfois avec des couleurs qui changeait
tout ça et des personnages et on
traverse des émotions mais il n'y a pas
forcément une narration qu'on peut
comprendre de a à z c'est pas comme ça
que je travaille moi je serais plutôt
sur le leurs ressentis du spectateur
pendant ce spectacle cet homme une femme
sur une scène épurée kata est une oeuvre
exigeante
la compagnie revient le samedi 16 juin
pour un bal participatif à l'espace
saint quentin à montigny le bretonneux